we should go we should go we should
celebrate
kind of Brian counts out here thank God
dude he's not here so nobody wants that
[ __ ] guy around here you know
Fillion they got Sam triply who's I've
heard a guy in the world it's to get you
track me flying have there much pressure
from the people it's finally happened I
live in Hollywood because these guys
that booked me and then they call me hey
dude can we move it up an hour which
which is 10 minutes from now to go do
this podcast I'm on the other side of
the [ __ ] City they want me to get
here like I got some kind of a Jeffers
Jetsons [ __ ] airplane that could get
here I don't know dude yeah dad you want
it I don't how bad yeah but also is it
weird you're here yeah yeah Howie
doesn't want me to talk about all of us
Freddie texted me told me he was like I
can't be there on purpose that's what I
said yeah trips coming in I told me his
dad told no he's more my favorite lizard
people though like oh yeah there's
something there yeah why do you think is
east because he's coordinated his dad
CFR I mean that's cool I think there's
some good see if I'm sure there was some
cool Nazis out there too that were just
like listen I don't have to choose I
just need to check you know I'm married
to a Julius you know it's 9:00 to 5:00
March March March yells at us it's one
of the thing what you gonna do
pop on the fact that the [ __ ] Hitler
was a straight-up Tweaker yeah well they
all love drug math all day but it wasn't
all the Nazis were on meth was not the
whole thing
yeah and they marched you know and they
would lead and they would load them up
as hard as they could kind of like the
kamikazes they [ __ ] loaded them up
with [ __ ] [ __ ] before they went out
there I don't know that now you guys do
that too oh yeah look at the fought the
Nazis they were on so much ship because
and then they could march like through
the night yeah these guys March for 46
miles like yeah man no sleep yeah the
kamikazes they would pump them up with
[ __ ] to get them delusional on crash the
planes and that's what we lost war
because the Nazi stop fighting tried to
suck their own their own dicks the whole
time yeah what you're gonna do on speed
it's time yes you distract yourself a
long enough you know
here's the thing though Nazis did it
look at a scene where Japanese kamikaze
kamikazes did it a man but also anyone
you see on math Instagram these famous
famous people are like jet-setting like
they're in Dublin here than their New
York and yeah three hours of sleep what
do you think they're do oh they're all
they're all just drugged up you don't
want to speed but everybody's rocking
adderall like everybody's the same
literally in the agree D a doctor gave
it to you yeah so they think it's all
good yeah yeah for sure he's not doing
he was thinking about doing a bit but he
is this great thing where he goes can
the rocks inspirational but we talked
about like he's not so much steel when
he saw so much [ __ ] like that's not
really go look methamphetamine was used
to world war two and keep to keep troops
high and we're giving a Japanese
kamikaze pilots before the suicide
missions right to get you juiced up
before you [ __ ] die yeah I want to
get [ __ ] up before I die well if you
know you're gonna die give me the
strongest [ __ ] ever give it to me we
have a nice load the kind I would
[ __ ] I would vein myself right before
everyone watched rooms heroin heroin
rumors too long to kick in no why are
you but I'm in the air while I'm in the
air if I'm like in your t-minus five
minutes from crashing I'm [ __ ] give
me give it to me right away heroin in
the neck I wanna I wanna be nice in the
dick mouths mushrooms [ __ ] speedball
nice one yeah but what if you take
mushrooms you thought you might not want
to [ __ ] cliff Falls dog just go hard
[ __ ] yeah fly aways five how about last
night at the store I get a set no our
first time ever in the orm are you doing
what was it with some show that we do a
set there and I go oh I thought I was in
the main room and they go oh rogon has
two shows of the manor like well not in
Rogen's and I go what room laying like
oh you're know are my gosh it's all so
exciting for me
you've never been you've never done a
show in there never never done some
voodoo room that I've watched so many
people get broke in there yeah but let's
just break it listen to what [ __ ]
happen dude in the song I'm a minute
into it dude in the front row cool Falls
I see that the core my I'm like okay I
keep powering through
like a professional like a pro and his
girl goes no stop stop
he's having a heart attack and I go
excuse me she was he's having a heart
attack and I still I was like god I
think I was killing the crowd like the
left side laughs you can't see these
people aren't laughing I go he's their
doctor and I go oh my god I see the guy
like on the ground like this I go it was
there a doctor in here
it's guy goes I'm at you I'm a doctor
they get them like drag him out yeah
yeah and then I don't know what to do
and I go do I keep going the cow goes
keep going keep going that is the funny
way
so where was I they go you talk about
the county oh yeah the cat it's all new
bit to it in the couch so yeah dude it
was did they drag him out the the county
store guys like like one had a month he
like picked him up did he come - he came
- what if what if I you know asked me -
oh no he didn't takes me DM me today hey
he goes dude I'm sick I was the biggest
fan man it's not a heart attack I have a
heart condition and it's only happened a
few times but only privately because
it's never happened in public because
I'm so [ __ ] how old was this guy
30-something embarrass he's embarrassed
of a heart condition I should be
embarrassed about
I'm sorry I'm embarrassed by this
debilitating thing I literally can't
control no that's true that's not that
[ __ ] shouts out to that dude for
[ __ ] tongue in and out and going to
the show with a heart condition knowing
that won't happen I'm all [ __ ] up my
first set in the war but yeah I mean
probably scarred he's got a little bit
worse than you do he's the guy that
passed out of it god
his girlfriend's ever gonna let them let
him live that down you know that right
dude I can't take you anywhere mark hey
I shall keep ass out house they're
dragging him out she goes
this is so embarrassing you're his
favorite you should do something nice
for this guy I did I told my said let me
know any tickets you want man they're on
me you should go see him in the hospital
private shell private show
that will make it worse and more weird a
private show
I thought so will you have to do the
pulp fiction freaking with the heart
thing right now what is that with what
is that with what's that called
something pen no epi yeah epinephrine
that's what it is ready what do they
what do they put into you this like
Jesus blood yeah they put Jesus's blood
in sizes Gia's right in your hot body of
Christ blood of Christ in your home yeah
what you know when they ask when they go
is there a doctor room what if the guy
who had the heart attacks a doctor then
you're [ __ ]
yeah what if he doctor this [ __ ] room
dude this is my thing I didn't keep
joking about cuz I want to go is there a
doctor room I'm not I just play one on
TV I want to keep going I'm like or
whoever the whoever's running the store
last night I don't want em in the back
Mike keep going dude no you can't say
you can't deal without know what someone
has a heart attack you got to chill out
for a [ __ ] second that you can't just
like she deemed wrong about it yeah well
do ours all about yeah you know why do
ours the best you know why Comedy Store
comics are the best because there's no
host you at that dude if you join Diaz
just playing throughout the room there's
nobody can go go eat a little time you
got the right up yeah yeah go up there
and you know dogs stick like a grown-ass
man now the beauty is in my opinion when
they're killing when they're killing
like that like someone like des and
because there's no host I like it more
because then then not only is the
pressure but also the praise is on you
because it's like Joey gives you a dope
intro they're already on fire right you
know how to ride the wave your [ __ ]
money versus someone kills and like I
just did a show someone kills and a host
goes up and it's just eating [ __ ] for no
[ __ ] reason you're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing we also sometimes when
you're when they're introducing you I've
always had great intros I think Dane
Cook gave me the best intro ever and I
don't know him at all yet did What did
he say
just some really nice stuff he's got hot
damn dude that's calm you know give me
the worst ever I think and I love Nick
Kroll but Nick Kroll why would he say he
was whose national Shabbos this
this is like a month ago yes this guy
he's fight in UFC so give it up for
Brendan Shaw oh that's nice oh yeah
that's really nice well thank good setup
dude yeah man
thanks for telling it thank you thanks
for telling my past and thanks for
giving me any credibility right now that
I'm here I come out pee really this yeah
main room this guy went to Community
College 20 years ago give it up for this
is if I can give you honesty in biology
abortions just fake it just fake it
that's how I always just three baby
daddies [ __ ] fake it be fun fake it
this guy's awesome you've seen this guy
he's great blah blah blah blah blah
that's what every every pro fakes it you
know I mean or you just do a run why to
us who Ron White remembers everybody and
nobody at the exact same time everyone's
in droves I guess yeah you gonna love
this [ __ ] dude or you know he's ours
first of all the store or you know hold
on you know you are probably DS Diaz ROM
white to me when they hit I think Diaz
is way harder to follow it when he's on
fire he is no Punk yeah but if I follow
him okay I always expect to eat a dog's
I'm like okay well let's see and it just
goes what the vibe is different because
it did Chaz Thalia does the LEAs comedy
can be followed by your comedy pretty
easily that's completely different yeah
but but Joey is in like I'll let his own
lane of storytelling I feel energy it's
just so different it's like it's like
nothing you've yet but it's also
top-shelf edgy [ __ ] to talk about like
yeah he's talking about it yeah you are
go like hey I had a weird day driving
but like we just heard about eating ass
for 15 minutes dude I one time had the
followed Joey Diaz at a Joe Rogan show
in San Jose which is the equivalent of
middling for Van Halen
when the opening act is David Lee Roth
okay Joey goes up to us 15 minutes of
eating ass and I'm like what do I got to
follow this I go up there flatline for
about 10 minutes how long how long goes
this this was many moons you know it's
like dude now it's like I could follow
anybody I don't really care about it
like recently like atoms for making me
file Brian Holtzman and back in the day
that was a [ __ ] that was work that
work because he would either destroy the
room and everyone's like that's great
thing I've ever seen or he would just
piss everyone destroy the room and
everyone get mad oh yeah dude I've seen
him do that yell at a guy until he
walked out I didn't yell at him as he
walked him out she's but it's so funny
dude it's so funny to watch he plays
these mind games with people so much of
it that it's as a comic it's brilliant
how about as a fan it's probably hard
cuz you're like some Knights are [ __ ]
brilliant and awesome and some nights
he's angry and off and weird and but
that's the story that's why it's so good
but I thought nobody else is doing that
anywhere anywhere ya know why is the
store jumpin when no one else is well we
got podcasts are constantly talking
about it and - look who came up there
and who is gigging there right now
everywhere else is like political
correctness gotta have diversity also on
these swords like flames of the room or
get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah but but also it comes from the door
guys to anybody or guys are all murdered
right now
monsters it is kind of creepy huh you do
some of the others see I mean I you do
some of the other rooms too you go there
how about trying to do other people's
rooms that they asked me to come do them
like I like Melo does a bunch of
different rooms there that's great well
anybody that has a different show else
like that we feel the improper foul oh
you mean outside of the gap vibe yeah no
they're totally different vibe [ __ ]
well here's it's funny I got one that
got the door guys sometimes or come
there and just light that please like in
Montreal it's so funny every time when I
go there it's becoming more and more
like what I think it should be where the
crowds are like I did a catalan Jeff oh
yeah countdown said you open for
challenge down ones that come across the
street what'd he say said you bumped no
is that what he [ __ ] said is that
what he [ __ ] said and wait to see his
old ass later today [ __ ] I didn't
phenomenal sorry I didn't do leg kicks
[ __ ] loser Road jokes [ __ ]
no I did great actually it was really
[ __ ] no I'm just proud no but the
crowd is so but the crowd was so but
what I'm saying the truth is like I
think sometimes you go to those places
in your like I don't know if I can tell
this kind of joke here dude
not anymore a jfl they love local doing
this is the Emperor's New Clothes it
only exists if you believe in it that's
exactly right dude it's a dude on the
road so you know like what's real yeah
but by the talk on Instagram and in
Twitter what's here and here it's not
real no see people real people day in
day out you're on tour yeah I can go
[ __ ] straight Lerman Sacramento this
Friday
Marlo's come see me this doesn't come
out for a month and a half no but I'm
thinking it's French Canada so I'm like
oh man maybe their attitudes are
different about certain things you know
I mean because they're in their own
little world no they love the food they
love the de Ville from this raw [ __ ]
they like the raw [ __ ] they love that
[ __ ] people always do that and look at
the club's that are like I'm not gonna
say names are you going to road these
clubs they're papering everything
because it's all about old man we got to
like not offend anybody people want to
come to get moved they either want to be
laugh their ass off get pissed you know
they want a wide range of emotions for
the longest night comedy clubs were like
going the opposite way of music
television
I mean Breaking Bad you should just like
go [ __ ] you to your face and then we'd
have like people doing comedy
patty-cakes people want chaos why do the
black comics sell out The Improv because
they are the only ones allowed to go up
and be most raw and real on stage yeah
well for a white guys forever there was
this political correct [ __ ] that we
had the [ __ ] follow that we couldn't
talk by anything running the running
comedy cast forever I started watching
who's selling tickets and it's all the
edgy guys it's to do to go up there and
flame throw the room that's what people
want to see ya betta walk patty-cakes
[ __ ] and that's why these other
clubs in the cut in LA can't sell a
ticket because forever they bought into
this diversity everybody gets a chance
let's keep it like [ __ ] you know
politically correct and they'll go see
that once and I like [ __ ] that ain't
gonna spend a dollar on that again and
they won't come back
you gotta move people dude every other
form of entertainment is about this
trainwreck way of PR man go big go crazy
go weird let everybody talk about it
right Comedy forever is like no let's
keep them calm now
dude the bigger the better the
trainwreck the more people want to see
it they want to see something they can
talk about and that's my opinion and you
see it with ticket sales in LA it's why
the connoisseurs Rocking and the other
ones are doing whatever they can to
[ __ ] survive that's my opinion also
everything happens in waves though to be
fair dude like everyone has their time
right like the economy store was at a
low point for a long time - yeah The
Improv was on fire for a long time right
and it was like it was on fire first and
it wasn't yeah and it wasn't like the
talent was different it was just talent
shifts and who comes back to we're
different now though it's it's it's
different now it's just it's just it's
not as if one talent pool was more valid
than the other one right like I murmured
when I first moved to LA when swardson
and crew were murdering at the [ __ ]
improv right and that place was that
place was unstoppable unstoppable right
it's just it just it was a moment time
for that Club that made sense now the
comments or there will be another wave
of something else you know what I mean
but you don't know when and wanted it's
good to have but I feel like you could
island you could have both like you
could do well but if you look at why it
was pushing they all were pushing
something specific yeah they had
different agendas everybody had a
different agenda they didn't play out it
did improv the Laugh Factory a wonderful
clubs
I love playing them they are now
starting to come around that it's not
about hey look how cool this flyer looks
with this diverse group of people with
all these cool haircuts people want to
come and see real [ __ ] I did have good
haircuts oh yeah oh that's like my
sexual biracial person and it's cool
bisexual biracial Tuesdays come on up
Sam when you're on the road doughy is
that the when you say you're in
Sacramento is it you and Eddie Bravo
yeah Dahl conspiracy try and do it it's
great I used like I've had I used to
have naughty show crowds and they were
[ __ ] great and you could go off and
they were but this tin foil hat crowd is
[ __ ] phenomenal I remember being in
Tacoma and crushing and just being like
wow I'm getting Berk ricer laughs that's
how [ __ ] great these crowds are does
everyone show up in like tin foil some
do you know brick crusher pays for
laughs you know he pays fees
he implants laughs do you guys not know
that that's a true fact about lamb let
the internet know he he only sells about
30% of his tickets and the 70% he pays
people pays actors to come yeah man yeah
he didn't come to and he says overlap
overlap guy can I talk to him yeah so
Sam are you doing straight up stand up
on the road are you doing like to stand
up and there at the end we do Q&A with
the crowd and you do palm reading right
you're dead after the show I just let
people know what's happening I can't
believe you guys didn't take advantage
especially you and Eddie take advantage
of the area 51 the storming the [ __ ]
Bay yeah we can [ __ ] amateurs yeah
that's is that amateur hour why cuz only
punk-ass amateurs think of storming area
51 first of all Eddie doesn't believe in
space or any of that [ __ ] so he ain't
going i doesn't believe it hey we're not
gonna talk [ __ ] I love him he believes
whatever he wants what do you mean he's
not a I love Eddie wish I had him on TV
doesn't he think there's he thinks all
up space is fake yeah well I mean like
all our information comes okay here's a
joke anybody want to hear a cool joke
okay uh uh a Nazi a Scientologist a
Satanist and a pedophile walk into a bar
what do they do
wait say to get a Nazi a Scientologist a
pedophile in a what Satanist walk into a
bar what do they do
I don't know invent NASA that's who
invented NASA Jack Parsons Walt Disney l
ron hubbard and [ __ ] von Braun in
were the four were the Four Horsemen of
NASA they created NASA's show lucky
Collins not here right now yeah I know
he's lucky he's not here right now
cuz I would crush his dreams like the
last time I was here Brian what we're
talking about aliens and we were going
so hard at Brian yeah so do you believe
in space I do what what is his argument
or not believing in space he believes
that dude I'm like if you look at von
Braun right the Nazi who helped invent a
NASA on his we took over here right yeah
so basically after the Nazis were
defeated right yeah you answered an
expansion draft we're like the United
States England and Rush
got to draft their favorite Nazis and
they're like with the number one pick of
the draft the United States selects von
Braun right and they took him over and
he helped create NASA but why did you go
like this defeated the not because they
weren't defeated they just you know like
they weren't they just they all they all
ran to the Vatican the Vatican put them
in submarines and Sam to Argentina these
are just facts there's a ton of Nazis
there's tons of not well or died in
Argentina I fled Hill there was
rotschild
anyways going but they had to leave it
there was a roster 100% his father was a
Boris I cants to to start about up being
a baker or something like that and he
his mother was a basically house help
made for a Baron Rothschild Baron
Rothschild knocked him up she fled had
all this all his head Hitler a loss
Hitler ellos ellos Hitler ellos ellos
has his doctorate in conspiracies so
deep out there it would take me weeks to
just go through everything and figure it
out I feel like out if I got high I
would start to get into that world than
I do I am balls the Bible talks about
aliens talks about reptilian what Bible
basically Virgin Mary got a train ran on
her by aliens that's the whole story
dude that's how Jesus is an alien Jesus
is par le and he's like the super [ __ ]
he's like almost like Superman II I love
you did I really know you think that
whole things but I mean that within the
Bible that's what it says where do you
where do we go when we die well you know
there's a couple things there's called
it's called the Tibetan Book of the Dead
okay and basically almost like the story
through the matrix basically you die and
when you die these beings appear and
they look like your relatives they're
like hey man we love you we've been
waiting for you jerk off the weird [ __ ]
but we're gonna let that go
I don't know what add ricotta to because
there we see every what everything yeah
there was yeah places I've sucked my
dick they're gonna my grandparents let
me describe hey so why would they want
to watch that and so supposedly they
tell you to get back into they go into
the light and then the light you get
reborn and you're born into this
supposedly where energy packs and if you
look at the moon there's some [ __ ] with
the moon the moons a little crazy dude
you ever notice that some the moon
[ __ ] the moon is like nothing else in
the universe in our galaxy it is the
only thing that has a perfect orbit we
never see the other side of the moon
right it's why is it there it's too big
it doesn't even make sense why it's
there why is it there it's too big a lot
of people think it's a [ __ ] energy
collector dude now write that when you
die your energy goes up there these
lizard people feed off our energy and
that'll accent you now here's the whole
thing the game pac-man right you ever
played pac-man when pac-man's close was
it look like a [ __ ] moon so you got
these ghosts going around when pac-man
eats at what happens it goes back into
the regenerator and gets reborn okay
this is this is this is cows here he
kicked you in the face this is this is
too much you're gonna make a man in the
moon no I'm just saying there are [ __ ]
like that that a moon the moon is just a
big beautiful thing that that that we
like to look at that's all it is
it's just a planet sure about chicks and
working out Shriekers and not wearing
any socks I there's only two ways to go
you either talk about conspiracy
theories or chicks working out at
sneakers there is no middle ground
anything you guys touch people up the
conspiracy I find it interesting no it
is interesting but also it's just it's
just as valid as it is it's not valid to
me like like anything else in the world
that's why I can never pay too much
attention or time if there's space a
space is real in the moon's real you
know but but but it's fun no no no
that's as valid as his point that's why
I'm saying like the guy that says to
[ __ ] the moon is fake is just as
valid to me as the guy that's like no
science I'm supposed to be do yeah but
I'm just no no because I just don't have
time I just I'm like okay great
you're both right it's fine not like it
Jean our unit but you are though no I
know there's a move I guess okay have
you been up there not happy how do you
know you look up what about what did
they ask the same the moon is in our I
believe that there's a moon in the sky
or a sure but but if somebody goes and
it's sucking yeah see from souls like
path man dude sometimes I feel like I
can see the lizard lizard people late at
night on the moon just just looking down
in our atmosphere
one time I jerked off just looking at
the moon it was so pretty wonderful the
crevices got me hard it's [ __ ] well
that's all faith bro what can I tell you
some real [ __ ] wait let me tell you
something not to get to let's get off
conspiracy there because yeah but this
lady my special I talk all about the
stuff that's available at Jesus guys
minutes Sam but so when they do like the
buzz aldrin like the moon landings yeah
they do whole anniversary do you think
they never I see it I just laugh because
I laugh at it cuz I think of you biggest
thing you've what when you do interviews
do they always want to ask you about
their when I ask you about your UFC
fighting why you about your special
doing why she about the do you find
yourself talking a lot about that in
interviews do you do that honestly yeah
well yeah this guy went to the [ __ ]
moon and talked about it one time he did
one interview and he's never done an
interview again on it you tell me you
want the [ __ ] moon and you did one
interview is that true chin how do we
know if that's true do only do wanted
every that before to ever wants to talk
about it what if he doesn't want to talk
about why would do the dog would talk
but maybe there's not much to talk about
he's like he's like it's sandy hey dude
you've heard that right you can relate
to this I'm gonna give you I'm just just
to be devil's avenues this is what you
do to think about it like this you know
the first guy that climbed Mount
Kilimanjaro you know you know well do
you know how long he spent up at the top
how long five minutes
yeah okay so sometimes the journey is
greater than the accomplishment you know
that in comedy we find the exact right
thing
we got never climb it it's the climb hey
listen listen he's the first my point is
my point is just like anything else in
comedy and in life
sometimes when you achieve the thing the
journey was so much stronger that it's
kind of almost a letdown when it happens
so there's something that saddens you a
little bit about getting a special about
getting and TV spot about getting breeds
dude sometimes these things listen
hey listen you wanna play devil's
advocate the moon is amazing lizard
people I'm saying it's found me cheese
it is man no it's good into satellites
good aliens I heard it's either Gouda or
goat so do you know that all the [ __ ]
wait hold on let me call the let me
finish yeah when you achieve things
sometimes they're not as satisfying as
you thought they were going to be when
you achieve something so great like that
if you do believe that don't you think
that there's a part of him that was like
I don't know man it was incredible what
do you want here's the other thing what
do you want to say about it but here's
the other one
what would you like him to say I think
he has an ego where that like that's
he's the only guy she's a moon hot
living who sells either lazy balls and
he's give him dude if listenmi listenmi
do the same but sometimes sometimes the
journey is so wonderful you can't
express it that way why is he showing up
to these of them because he gets paid
make sure he gets paid how is he
supposed to make money makes no sense
going to court answering questions about
the moon at these events though but he's
never given an interview later you
shocked they [ __ ] shot dude a [ __ ]
quote the greatest accomplishment ever
I know God you know what you've talked
about it what John's cool about that
something's very cool about that funny
cool cool what do you want you wanted on
the Today Show why not you want to I not
why why would he want to do someone in
their greatest accomplishment ever
it's not like he ran a [ __ ] Oh a
one-minute mile or two men four-minute
mile thank you like I'm talking about
one dude or a couple dudes first place
people ever to go on the moon this giant
thing that's been made this humongous
moment in the Cold War this guy's done
one interview after he landed one what
it makes no sense that makes company
other guys done interviews maybe he's
shy he has not had the other guys okay
had the other guys done interviews
haven't really looked into them well
that's something we definitely need to
look into what if he's the one guy
that's like I really want a putter
what is that me ponch that guy in the
face plaza if he's only done one
interview all agree with saya that's
shady as [ __ ] podcast material for have
never seen you after moon landing that's
it and they can't agree on anything but
after they land they can't agree one guy
says he saw stars the other ones like
God we didn't see sucker did we see
starts are like it's like it's time out
time out so we didn't land on the moon
is what you're saying why if you really
want know what I believe
well the Hollywood rights I think that
was faked I think we were actually on
every planet with some advanced ass
technology that was faked for the Cold
War in the [ __ ] just to beat the
Russians and they can't [ __ ] really
show you everything we got because it's
super advanced this is a problem with
conspiracy theories there's no problem
there's no there's no way to prove it's
impossible it's a never-ending fight
you'd have to scour the internet in
libraries for months and months and
months and months even find out if if
that's true because he might have done a
million interviews but you wouldn't know
the only way we know that how would you
know because I've studied it we're on
the you know yet forever but the
internet isn't providing everything well
use though but here's the thing maybe if
you go or the earth is flat right these
are flat I sound like you can you can
disprove that but is it flat years we've
never done it no to me we live in the
simulation I'm not a flat earth guy I
respect the flower with people believe
whatever you want simulation I believe
we live in a simulation yes so we look
at a simulation and the thing we live on
is is not flat i I don't know what we
live I so I'm telling you I believe we
live on a ball being very bad on the
ball why do I think we live in a ball
because I was told that as a kid I never
did any study and everyone's like what
what about this video what about that
video about this video there's all sorts
of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] fisheye lens all
that stuff I think we live on a ball why
because I was told as a kid I have done
no research on my own any of the studies
that they say any of the [ __ ]
formulas that they tell you to tell you
that
Paul I have done none of it and 99% of
people who call me crazy have done no
research either you are just
regurgitating what you were told as a
kid I am fine with it being a ball I
believe we live in the simulation okay I
respect that but no one's calling you
crazy in here no no I'm not in here
people you think people call you crazy
here this is a safe place
yeah your safe place this is so say it's
good place [ __ ] it I'm just Bruce Lee
fighting 80 dudes Graham and social
media not a safe place yeah no people
yeah yeah let me tell you let me tell
you talk chicks and working she working
out and sneakers and sock in dude let me
give you a let me give you one little
piece of not conspiracy anything at all
but it's it's relative to where we're
talking about absorbing energy in the
universe this is kind of cool
Luke Perry was in Tarantino's movie it
was his last role on time yeah and I
just watched it and it made me sad
because I was like man that satisfy that
dude passed away you know and then I was
at home and I was looking up Luke Perry
he just kind of doing research on him
for fun cuz you know I don't know
whatever and anyway his there was a lie
put out to the world that he was
cremated and and spread a Nash is of his
farm in Tennessee his daughter and this
is provable as she did an interview
recently and said that was not true I
don't even know who said that he was
never cremated they put him in what's
called an infinity suit do you know what
this is no this is [ __ ] why well it's
not it's not it's not as amazing it's
all it's kind of beautiful
there's there's this guy that the
scientists develop this infinity suit
that says we're filled with toxins our
bodies are loaded with toxins and that's
a fact
right and your toxins whether you're
burnt or put in the ground are pushed
out in the universe in a very bad way
that's how they they say the toxins
bleed out in the and see their mushroom
stew it's called infinity suit so what
happens is you get wrapped and buried in
this and and and mushrooms and other you
can you can pretty much make any kind of
herb or anything
fungal grow on you to take the toxins to
use them for their growth instead of
putting them back out in the universe
and then you will turn into a [ __ ]
garden a human garden I love the article
talk to all of that about where to bury
you he got buried at his farm in
Tennessee but they just know you're not
a coughing no no no no no no you're in
the earth you're just a thing yes are
they wrapping the hole
in the earth insight right I always add
chopped up and then put in like some
kind of [ __ ] mulch yeah for a tree
yeah but I'll do that infinity shoot so
here's what's crazy su infinities want
finish soon then bury me in Laurel
Canyon you want to be in Laurel Canyon
near the record studio just like
somewhere along with [ __ ] nah dude
cuz that's too busy is too much going on
I want to be out in the middle of
nowhere yeah Lorcan there's a lot of
land in this country lot away Jeremy on
the middle the note I want to be Montana
you're been in Montana yeah it's got a
flat boy hey [ __ ] you it's not flat at
all first of all and second of all it's
not boring it's [ __ ] beautiful
there's no money there's mountains up
there and I'm from Denver though you
know be cool same mountain range yes a
mountain range sorry I know it's flat
and it's the same mountain range now
Montana's gorgeous orcas I'll bury
yourself in Colorado out by the airport
conspiracy theory let's not get into the
airport let's not go crazy crazy binds
it on the walls out from [ __ ] Denver
why why does that mean owned all that
land out there why - now you're queen
baby with gas so I already know all that
[ __ ] yeah she owns the land she'll go to
land by dia yeah a ton of it and you
know that the airport was built once and
then built again you know yeah I think
it's weird that the Queen just came out
and said she's related to the Prophet
Mohammed yeah what's up with that [ __ ]
dude Anunnaki dawg Anunnaki they created
us and then they created a visa so weird
dude these paintings at DIA ain't the
whole story the fact that all this
attention has been brought to them and
they haven't taken it down says
everything don't care does it people cuz
if you cared enough you would like look
what happened at the improv
people complained about those stupid
[ __ ] paintings and they took em down
finally they finally painted over them
oh the dolphin guy yeah y'all the yeah
yeah while India island to island by the
way that guy campaign of the [ __ ] out of
a dolphin you go down to the beaches and
he could paint a [ __ ] dolphin like a
[ __ ] whales whales no it's
whales look Vaseline fell on the guy
that made it and killed that's right it
doesn't make sense it does make sense no
no not him and not just a guy not just
the guy that Nader Emily not just the
guy that made it all for he was the
[ __ ] engine he was the brains behind
it it wasn't just like a worker it was
like the man that had
idea for the Bronco to be in the air
like this whole thing that someone else
died to around it when they're
installing it though I don't know may I
so people were watching build this
they're like why are you pulling out
that much land yeah why are you pulling
out all this land it doesn't make sense
for the amount of construction to do it
why they ended up bulldog oh that's gin
dude why is that on the wall at DIA
because this is okay that's my soul yeah
my maggot round tunnel same as that man
they want to scare they want to scare
away tourism did the brain it's - it's
just over what is that I think that was
in one of my bags that fell out of one
of my bags when I was going to Denver
one time
that's ndia - that's the creepiest
that's not in DIA it oh it is that is
the airport the background yeah well
that's awesome anyway let me jump
backwards yeah off your [ __ ] phone
trip - yeah we're here for us okay I
don't care about the chicks we're here
for us the kid do you're gonna be garden
infinity suit right I don't wanna be
buried one you just changed my life -
thank you yeah I'm kind of into so much
are they I do [ __ ] get it money when
you talk about money you can okay firing
the cake I get 20% off that might be
able to me guys go to infinity shoot
calm use the promo code fighter in the
erotica to get yourself 20% off an
affinity see we do mushrooms and other
spores we're gonna get you more soon but
go to my infinity shoot comm by the way
is infinity so do they sell it no it
says over $5,000 dude that's five g's
dude so then far less over regular
burials that's how much like a [ __ ] of
death look at this suit they put you in
like it's a weird thing like let me see
go where is also go back up wait you go
up look at that up more MORE
hold on call it coin yeah that's time
some weird [ __ ] shell yeah bury me some
Eyes Wide Shut - ginger scroll out like
that the bullet points there
here's the thing though let's say all
the three of us die in here in cat and
chin are like all right we'll just put
them in the yards back here you can't
just have me dead bodies all over the
goddamn place
yeah like everyone wants to do it's
gonna come back and haunt you what do
you mean you can't have that well yes
you can no you can't just bury a dead
body in your backyard it's not no dude
this you have to get buried legally
somewhere yes you have to get buried
like with it within the laws of where
bodies can be very much
it's your own property you can bury
yourself on your own property I could
until my girl could bury me on my fuuu
bury yourself here to send me out cell
you own it what are you talking of
course you can I don't think so dude do
you have you eat I buried yourself here
under this table dude you can you can be
buried in your own [ __ ] back walls
donation people asking for them for they
know all did they know just answered
your own question why do we keep turning
to Agent P before because they have the
answers they made the computers they're
searching on they know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about they have the
insider laws in California embalming
your car Balog see you gotta have a
permit to bury yourself in your backyard
that's odd dude and this is why I love
libertarians why do I need a permit to
bury myself pay the government dollars
on the way out we can't have you burying
yourself on [ __ ] sunset why well no
no we're not talking jail we're talking
about my own way let me tell you why let
me tell you may be nasty because your
your land is never your land your land
is my land
because you you never really own the
land that you own just cuz it's yours
you're still renting it from the from
the government it's not just because you
only own when they pay it off you okay
you buy a house cash what do you have to
pay every year what is it what's that
called of interest you have what no no
what do you pay every year you're a
homeowner axis how do you pay taxes
right you'll never not pay taxes on
[ __ ] property good you own it doesn't
mean it's yours you're still paying to
rent that land from so they say you own
it outright as you are allowed to put
[ __ ] on it yeah but they still owns a
physical or land for that yes they still
own the property on the line you owned
the stuff on top of the grass they owned
the [ __ ] earth you'll never own the
earth why are some crazy do you don't
[ __ ] Queen Elizabeth owns technically
all the United States all of Canada all
the UK all of Australia and all of New
Zealand she technically owns it all
which means that even avalue she
technically owned what does that mean
she can't like you know just run amuck
now here's the thing dude
there is that's why I want to keep guns
she can't sell us straight I want to
keep guns in case she comes by
that people I think I read somewhere
that this is crazy but that she actually
gets a percentage of our taxes do you
know the IRS is not a US government
department
it is a private Department owned by a
foreign entity that you don't pay your
taxes to the US government you paid to a
foreign entity and then what happens
with that money I believe the IRS is
operated by our United States government
no it's not yes it is sure how much you
want that well pay my taxes do you know
why are you doing this bro
look at him bro it's IRS that first well
I think it's higher as that is irs.gov
job so that means it's okay okay who
runs it look it up look at that I can
hear IBF or the is not a third party
banking system they don't it's IBF for
its IBF or W world banking some are you
the the IRS is not in each to the United
States but rather private corporation
because not created by positive law ie
an act of Congress and that therefore
the IRS does not have the authority
enforce Internal Revenue Code
that's as some people think that doesn't
say what do I can't just trust you honey
I want to know facts the the IRS is
owned in entities outside our country
see look at that this is this is this is
people making this up website yeah yeah
taxes go no our taxes we know where it
goes goes to a private entity go to fix
might the roads all right yeah the
United Sates Treasury collects access to
the Internal Revenue Service that's what
the apartment is Treasury does it would
it be cool if you knew a guy who
actually knew all this [ __ ] what oh no
yeah it goes here like you knew very so
much were fact there's somebody there's
there's a group of people that in there
because I got the IRS and see its
beginnings see it was look at it when it
was whenever started guys know that um
the Federal Reserve Act and that
personal income tax was signed by
Woodrow Wilson on Christmas Eve in the
dead of night when everybody was home
for the holidays and there was no vote
on them they were just put out by that
by this group of bankers and the it's
basically called
it's a book written on I called the
creature of Jekyll Island and it was
basically international bankers and that
was what a lot of people think the civil
war was about slavery it really wasn't
it was about ah it was about the Federal
Reserve the centralized bank and that
the British and I believe Spain or
France were to come on the side of south
and all they had to do was agree that if
they would have a centralized bank that
the British and French or Spanish would
come in on the side of the South Wow
keep it up Cynthia you know there's got
to be a theory behind the you know the
theory behind all this is if you talk
about it enough and you have enough if
you if you just talk if you read enough
of it and you believe enough of it it is
true this is my point
who knows if anything if anything you
don't know it's true I know it's know
you don't but you don't know no you
don't know you know I felt nutty I love
you with all my heart I've you don't
know I do know you don't you ret you've
just read things written by whom I've
been just right multiple people doing
multiple ways how are they valid then
how do we know anything that's my point
so it's all [ __ ] everything's
[ __ ] most [ __ ] is both very things
most [ __ ] is [ __ ] all shits [ __ ]
no [ __ ] is [ __ ] okay I will accept
that because let me recall things are
[ __ ] if you're just like Kings are
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] then I've most
things I love you about my heart think
about it like that is crazy
who've out who vouch who is of articles
that you've read that have a Valerie so
so the good you can say I read an hour
we did not get independence in 1776
that's all [ __ ] that's all [ __ ]
we don't know that we don't know we
don't know we don't know don't know
okay I'll respect that because if you're
saying all information is [ __ ] I'll
respect for the most part I say my
informations I say most [ __ ] is not just
conspiracy things because you what
you're saying is [ __ ] just as much
as what we're told is bullsh correct
that's my point so you accept you saying
that the Queen owns all these countries
is just as valid as someone going there
was we were at peace with the Indians
when they took out when we took over the
land I'm totally fine with that if
you're telling me all information are
Mohsen for most informations [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's why it's hard for me to
believe anything because if you say
things if we all say things enough we
all believe so let me ask you a Cindy
what do you believe in dude
almost nothing
I'm being serious I believe in almost
nothing this is nothing so I believe I
believe it I believe in singing I
believe in I
okey no no I don't believe in I don't
believe in karaoke doesn't even exist
you don't believe that I rock the
[ __ ] goddamn Comedy Jam
I've [ __ ] said no recently chance you
rocked it video crush what do I believe
that you believe in I believe I believe
in I don't I don't believe in fate I
believe that we are I believe in self
choice I believe we all have choice this
stuff you're listing is some weird kind
of like energy shift no not unless your
actual I believe humans I believe humans
make choices to move seamlessly through
the [ __ ] universe and you make
mistakes you do things that that are
positive for you physically yeah that's
it boom that's it yes we are
metaphysical that's what we are but like
like do you believe like in the in like
JFK was actually shot do you believe do
you believe in 1992 the US Dream Team or
whatever year was that's long ago do you
believe that nope made up okay cool I
believe I'm totally cool what you're
saying I'm cool that I think everything
is happening and nothing is happening
come on if we receive on dude
do you believe bro no no no if we're a
simulation like Sam says we are we're
saying you believe that too of course
but do it then you don't know Andrew do
you believe that my album is available
for sale on Friday no we don't know no
in fact go it's free or a fact I would
tell everyone watching the show right
now that that's not true that Sam album
is not available but there's no more
like oh yeah I maybe should investigate
and you should preorder it and I tell
you now check out it life I doubt it I
doubt it cuz most things are both shame
though it doesn't believe in it I like
to take middle ground let me check in
with pretty Caitlin hotter in here by
them I know this is a hot
see it's working out there it's working
outside not in our unit and if we open
the door with her own help mo now
village sounds too much the [ __ ] does
this end yeah those guys are out there
tic-tac type in Google and stuff anytime
you're in a production office all
they're doing is googling
what they're working on you know why you
know why Sam exactly who are they saying
I don't man shadowmen god none of these
people are employed by anybody they just
show up check out my special yeah what
do you guys really I don't think he's
crazy
Oh what is I think he has very strong
opinions but I think a lot of people do
who you you talking about you sir okay
yeah but Jen what a bully do you believe
how Santino believes it's fine what do
you think chin no I wouldn't is leave
what do you I'm trying to figure out
that the temperature here the older I
get the more I don't believe in a lot of
stuff and I just don't know what's going
on we're on the same page yeah the more
stuff I learned the more like I don't
say that so so so so Shabab didn't let
me finish
let's pair our brains a you and I right
do you what do you what do you really
believe in and on a very baseline level
I'm not talking about the depths of JFK
I mean just on a baseline didn't believe
in at the end of baseline level on a
base when you lay your head down at
night what really what do you really
believe in I believe like family the bed
Pam loves you
simple nonsense that's what I'm saying I
believe in trying to make myself and
those around real feel good and that's
almost an awesome do you believe almost
all I've gotten that the US government
faked weapons of mass destruction to go
into a foreign country do you believe
that happened I do believe that okay so
I mean what are we talking about no
because when we go I don't believe in
anything Malak but I sense that I think
the government does I don't matter those
moves for ya
for the greater good essentially the
greater good for the country of the
greater good of the country which is
more money rich people yeah well thank
God well we all hope to be those people
yeah
unless you [ __ ] your way into it
hey Sam you know right alright guys a
yeah and you know what I ate at that
ping pong pizza place does exist it do
life in there does not exist I think
this guy's talking about Mandela fact
that yep it doesn't exist you think it
exists but it does not excite well I eat
pizza at the place where kids were so
what hope you have a ping pong yeah I
mean what's pizza see how do I know it's
real because you said it's real try it
bro
I I ate it last night the Comedy Store
where is it now
in my belly the [ __ ] and that's another
[ __ ] lie they fed us that our
stomachs are processing food lie lie lie
let's go to current event that's a lie
do you see what I'm doing yes you got a
lot of tabs open dawg yeah there's a
plight here at life and this is another
of okay I'll let you read it I was hey
guys brette a job here for stitch fix
you know how would you describe your
look in one word casual sophisticated
playful however you dress take all the
thinking out of it stitch fix is an
expert personal stylist that can help
you look your best whatever your style
is personal style is like a fingerprint
you got to be your own look at me I got
a pink shirt on no socks what up I could
use stitch fix so I look better day in
day out sticks [ __ ] got you looking
correct sticks [ __ ] is an online
personal styling service that delivers
your favorite clothing brands right to
your door to get started go to stitch
fix dot-com slash fighter and answer a
few questions about your style and your
personal shopper will ship you a box of
clothes shoes accessories all-in-one
there's no commitment required you only
pay for what you keep shipping exchanges
and returns are always free there's no
reason not to look good these days with
stitch fix we got you covered baby plus
point our styling fees automatically
apply towards anything you keep from
your box you never have to think about
looking good ever again with stitch fix
get started at stitch fix comm slash
fighter get 25% off when you keep
everything in your box
that stitch fix dot-com / fighter look
good
stitch fix sit ditch stitch fix dot-com
/ fighter you know at 36 years old my
teeth are starting to get a little
crowded a little jumbled up and you know
that happens cuz we get older your teeth
go you know what we want to move around
a little bit when a wiggle around
Brian's not here he'd be the perfect
poster boy for this Brian's teeth were
terrible they were awful
worst I've ever seen one was brown
decided to fall all the way back
look at Brian's teeth now flawless
flawless thanks to candid candid is an
orthodontist who is licensed in your
state and creates a treatment plan for
you and Canada only uses experienced
orthodontist they create a 3d preview of
what the final results will look like
and that's what they did for me because
I need to get my fronts these Chiclets
lined up line them up all you got to do
is approve it and guess what can it cost
sixty five percent less than braces
you're gonna rock braces at 35 nah man
you're definitely not save thousands
thousands have straighter brighter teeth
in an average to six month no one should
have a messed up grill there's no
excuses there's no excuses and thanks so
the fighting the kid I'm excited to get
my clear aligners from Canada and get
these centum a SAP alright I'm sticking
my freaking bottom teeth you guys are
only one step away getting straight a
brighter teeth to learn more at candid
co.com slash fighter use code fighter to
get seventy five dollars off to get your
grill fixed what's it worth man what's
it worth to you straight teeth priceless
that's candid co.com slash fighter code
fighter for seventy five dollars off
candied co.com slash fighter fix your
grill all right we're back you want
support you want vitality total human
optimization total gut health total mike
mitochondria took krill oil shroom tech
immune be active be complex yeah he
minerals off the entire by me
they got everything you want yes check
yep they got it all Brian keep listening
out all the stuff when it's on my page
they do rain they got total keyed off
your Aikido kid like myself
they got workout gear they get the best
supplements on Planet free bird audit
you guys know them there were some of
the best names in the world there's a
reason you say the best Hughes head can
save 10% off their workout gear their
supplements go to audit calm slash
fighter and save 10% off everything
optimized so Brendan looks like I'm
gonna be wearing a whoop well here it is
why because I convinced you because my
thick ass I've been working out and I
begin these reads on whatever device I'm
work down they go you print a thousand
no you print 1200 now you didn't bro
because now whoop is the most calculated
accurate device you can Rock look pretty
thin like a bracelet but it also talks
about sleep sleep is important sleep
attraction how much sleep you need heart
rate how hard you can go for the next
workout your maximum maximum levels
where you're at it's the most accurate
calculation I want advice I want the new
whoops trap 3.0 which includes new
upgrades and hardware and unlocks a
suite of new software features for their
app the whoops crap 3.0 now has a
five-day battery life damn yeah bro
sprout and guess what though this
attracts my heart rate a hundred times
per second 24/7 recovery we got you
covered
rest recover your workout how many
calories are you burning everything man
they take all that thing count it's the
most accurate detailed it's it's wo p
it's a whoop strap yep whoop in out in
out number like that whoop did I get it
how do I get it dude how do you get it
you go to whoop calm that's wh oo p calm
use the code fighter and get $30 off
your whoop membership yes optimize the
way you train get shred City with me get
shred City whooped calm promo code
fighter $30 off so a ten year old boy is
currently being charged for assault for
playing a dodgeball game oh boy
so he
in school they were playing dodgeball
and there was one kid who has some sort
of disease that basically if his head
gets hit he gets [ __ ] up so why is he
exactly so that apparently it's happened
in the past where he's played dodgeball
this very game has gotten hit in the
head and he'd suffer several injuries
teachers didn't take him out of this
game this time around a kid was playing
accidentally threw the ball and it
landed on his head the mother of that
child is now saying that that kid did it
on purpose and that was dodge ball is
that the kid that is the kid and now
he's being charged for assault course
he's black it's just unbelievable to me
Walton all-white school it says he's the
only black part no I'm kidding no but
you know what you know what it really is
though keeps growing the school knew
that he had a brain condition they
shouldn't have let him play it but ma
wouldn't be even near know but if they
knew he had the condition and the mother
was like he wants to wants to play it's
like well then you die you die but you
got to be [ __ ] law is life bro if you
want to [ __ ] play dodgeball with the
kids and you have a condition that might
you might have something for boxers like
but you know recently two boxers died
it's unbelievable should have like
that's that's they know the
repercussions they go way forward look
what you just said look at the first
thing under the picture well Linda Lee
and her son are black while the other
child in the incident is white there you
go my whole thing is like I hate when
adults apply adult [ __ ] to children like
when you have a ten-year-old they're
like charge him with like sexual harass
it's like he's ten like trying to like
[ __ ] these kids before they're even
adults my hitting them with these
[ __ ] charges it's all circumstantial
cuz looking like this you know about
this story those kids are gonna be
charged as adults those kids I threw
that rock over the highway and killed
that guy they should yeah well but see
that's funny so kids will be kids I did
[ __ ] up [ __ ] we said throw rocks and
do do [ __ ] up [ __ ] but they threw a
rock so big that it went through a guy's
windshield and it killed him hold on
hold on and they threw it with the
intention to kill wrong incorrect these
kids are teenagers they threw the roxas
they wanted to [ __ ] up a car oh my god
Oh have you seen the tatin fifteen
attacks no that guy died hello laughing
my ass I'll do ya
I'm not saying after the fact whatever
they said I'm saying they weren't trying
to murder somebody they weren't like we
should kill so they were like let's see
we can throw a rock off a bridge and
[ __ ] up a car you did dumb [ __ ] like
that when you were kids I did it you
know I didn't but I would never try I
was never violent cat would never
thought was cool to see pain and stuff
of course not I'm just saying my thing
is these kids never had the intention on
murdering a human being they don't know
the repercussions thereof and I see I
have 14 F if I took a giant boulder I
was like yeah I'm gonna sauce up a high
rock hit a car that's all someone's
gonna die boy you were a big boy no you
were a big heavy worker you are big
there were you at 14 not I was a late
bloomer he was huge D was four when he
was my rock you till seventeen yeah I
was like I was I was not I was I was
small 385 pounds when he was nine you're
a fat kid fattest kid in the name what
else we got black and white that was
about black and white by the way more
than anything in the world the article
should have been called race it was just
because the school was trying to cover
their ass for having this child in that
type of situation school choice that kid
should even be at that school yeah he
should be somewhere special where they
can like my term the whole time so
you're just gonna be he just can't get
hit in the head I mean school ball you
just can't play gym sports we had a kid
that had to sit out for gimli tag he had
to sit out for gym and he complained
about it I want to play he couldn't he
had a thick condition bad ticker he had
a bad ticker and they could and he
complained I want to play one up ins you
said no that's it you don't get the
[ __ ] play we don't you can't die here
we can't afford that we can't even
afford lunch
you can't die here the tender discussion
what else you got that
so a Amazon delivery person stole
somebody's dog after delivering their
package that pisses me off yes fat
wiener dog yes that's the dog do they
want that thing what do you mean that's
so cute
[ __ ] jerk little joke that dog is fat
okay that's so good lovable whoa no but
then somebody loves that animal bro
just like you love your child what if
someone took your your kids not
good-looking what if someone took your
kid your kid is a little goon
did my kid who beat you up a little
refried mean your kid is a little [ __ ]
your little pinto bean someone could
steal him and you and some other guy
would go who would steal that ugly [ __ ]
and then you go that's my kid hey first
of all talk about a fat wiener dog here
compared to sons shame thing
look at that [ __ ] look at how cute
that can what they do with them so the
woman who took the dog later posted onto
Craigslist that the dog was on sale for
$100 oh my god neighbors ring alarm they
had the camera system set up when they
found out that their neighbor's dog was
missing they said oh we saw somebody
with your dog does this look familiar
and they realize it was the person
dropping off their Amazon pass shady so
the woman was found arrested and the dog
is returned family should be able you
should be able to beat people up in
public for that you should be able to
use jungle battery for that at public
punishment yes let's [ __ ] floggings like
Aussies you had also wiener dog put up a
fight though you know here's my old fake
yeah this legs are so small why they're
stupid that's my point
listen you're upsetting some wiener dog
people dude not a wiener a hoppy - dude
they're like the trans with the trans
your fake common horse you [ __ ] with the
five people they show up we don't know
people come out dude to support their
cause dude I sell out [ __ ] shows
doing just fat wiener dog conventions
thank you and they pay really so a
couple of days ago armie hammer was
viral because a video of his son sucking
on his toes was posted onto Instagram
and a lot of people had a lot of mixed
feelings about it's so stupid no one in
has kids not mom so he's joked around go
and have for assault seven minutes they
do not need the kids that - he's it's
not an arm an arm a hammer so armie
hammer is pretty good looking like stuck
on his [ __ ] toes for a long time that
guy's a babe weird
by the way to be way longer than seven
minutes if I did it oh yeah I can't call
my toes sucked down by two 300-pound
chicks
we were just had a party - like we suck
your toe I'm like I mean cross off the
list but any suck into through a little
barbecue sauce on it may
right he's an economist what ranch you
know just like hey dude I'm making
dreams come true
that's not turning anybody on getting
your feet sucked yeah it's not my fight
random people in public it doesn't mean
asked me 585 hey give me a pound for
that a 1985 yeah there's a print I'm so
people are freaking out over this but
it's so stupid the kids obviously just
[ __ ] around
everyone thinks a sexual no no it's not
his kid it's his neighbor's kid that's
why it's we kidnap them video that's my
point
like why even do they don't wash it like
that with your son sobs uh point is you
wouldn't post some weird [ __ ] like that
if your kid was licking on your toes
you're not posting it if you did
I'm calling you a go broke take that
down now yeah do it but it's harmless
like I saw to your point I don't give a
[ __ ]
no but there's nothing sexual about this
it's also feet alright I think people
are gross out cuz its feet yeah it's a
two-year-old being like dad I love kids
LeBron's dad's feet it's like just weird
but it's it's nothing here's my thing
I'm not posting is amazing are we hammer
only getting 1,700 likes you're a movie
star
well that's repost that's repost his
look up on his walls his interview
probably I probably had a million over a
million views of people complaining
there's probably to be a trend on the
internet people letting their kids start
our toes not gonna post all about it or
post your dog sick and it tells us
something about a wiener dog sucking
toes probably some story right that was
honest no it's just a story think about
like this can we take a second real
quick to think about this look at this
go back up 1.2 million people follow ok
armie hammer is a bona fide
movie star right our friend Chris D'Elia
has 1.7 million followers boys almost at
a million here - are you
yep congratulations thank you and you
don't deserve any of those follow me
follow me follow these Falls no you know
what it really is though to think about
that I'm just putting a perspective
1.7 Chris made his career solely on a
stand up and it impresses me this guy is
in [ __ ] knows TV shows did not get him
the audience that he's got and up got
him was they end up in podcasting hold
on yeah
both chicks were showing up and getting
a whole readable wasn't did admit that
is for him but now still II on social
media yeah he's so [ __ ] funny on
there yes that's how it's gone that's my
point though so I think about the weight
of that is all I'm saying
this guy's shown on movie screens around
the [ __ ] ball what is what is this
thing whatever we want to be where you
want a burrito leo
but it's just it's I'm just saying
sometimes I think about that now go man
that's crazy how the [ __ ] how the
internet works have to [ __ ] in that
[ __ ] yeah but you know that's not none
of those are real I know that is well
the people people farms broken because
of the podcasts and the the fight stuff
right magnetic they're literally phone
before humor and yeah puts content
humorous content on their shows a bag
like imagine this I met just Chris got
in a [ __ ] Eminem rap video who did a
Instagram video for yeah yes nuts
that wasn't Eminem though we don't know
know was not even you don't know
anything see shut up alright what's the
next one let's see it's so hot in here
it's where it's fine this crushing very
very popular youtuber he's not popular
youtuber this guy's 11 million
subscribers be dying dude why are they
be die and he did eat chemical he went
oh no he went paragliding and never came
back so they found out okay
she should be back right now so they
took his GPS coordinates they found him
somewhere in the mountains he crashed so
they picked him up anything later that
night that is so sad dude I don't want
to say anything negative because that's
very tragic I know his friends and
family that's hurtful that sucks that's
said I can't go that poor guy just died
man how do we know he died that's okay
there you go nah this is what I do like
but here's where is he really
santino here's the other thing don't
paraglide but also again again don't
period is this what is this also this is
Barstow posting a paragliding thing
recently capitalizing and then this is
how looks I mean this is all crazy
paragliding is hey
right that's oh [ __ ] me don't so it's
within like Oh No thank you I don't know
how you can control yourself that that
look professional yeah yeah you're
probably not professional she was silent
he was a pilot he was like uh I'm pretty
sure it's pretty good perfect what is
that but also do you we also don't
paraglide but can I can I tell you
something though it's not nerve-racking
look that so awesome it does all right
but it's too narrow much no but it's the
same thing as those guys who do the bird
suit things value that exactly same kind
of chaos and also don't do that if
you're talking about it no but tone if
you're dope added no but don't know sob
but don't if you're hope at it why
wouldn't you do it
because the one time your dad died but
like this you used to fight yeah you
could die in a fight oh yeah and then
when UFC fighters ever died didn't guy
just [ __ ] die not saying no but
there's a guy for weigh-ins have died
nope name one the guys in Brazil not in
your system Brazil's that's some
[ __ ] jungle fight racist that's the
league's gonna fight it did sound racist
jungle people holy [ __ ] job you're gonna
get some kickback for that jungle
fighting that's illegal
dude these youtubers though like that's
so sad that I don't like to hear that
kind of he nodded but don't paraglide so
my son my son there's like I don't know
well you guys don't have kids but
there's a youtube channel this kid he
seems like Alex some [ __ ] he's a number
one elf Alex he's a number he's like
eight he's in the one youtuber most
money he's eight he unwraps stuff toys I
seen it and my son goes papa
I want this this fire truck and I'm like
yeah public it's fire triggers no no I
want the paw patrol Alex firetruck I'm
like I don't know Alex just maybe a
friend in school and then so I find it
right at the store I surprise him I find
it and I give it to him and I'm like
right now Papa let me show you how to do
this stuff and he was no no and new
every trinket in and all my god
everything knew exactly how to work this
thing all from this [ __ ] kid in his
videos look at this dude it said he
makes 22 million a year did you just see
that yeah done 22 million
playing with toys well here's what makes
me nauseous about this you know he's not
making all these melons parents rushing
yeah that's what's disgusting his mom is
talking real now you can't you can't do
it no this is YouTube that's that's
movies and television no no no wrong
there's a law that there's also when
you're under 18 mercial when you're
under 18 and you're and you are earning
money towards your name or towards a
trust it has to be put in protective
trust by the [ __ ] by the government
parents are not allowed to touch it and
my son did like uh like some he
literally can't tell us that money
it can take the dressing after did you
really know shady photo dude what did
your son do porno he thought you know
Hollywood popular again out here oh yeah
his lotta losers had a would I don't
what baby
he's the highest-paid youtube star huh
it's crazy man so [ __ ] just so you know
that guy you know that guy little NAS X
that has that song billboard number one
twenty two weeks in a row of all time of
all time no song no Beatles no Michael
Jackson nobody has been bigger than this
two different time though now I'm it it
doesn't matter the point is that's
insane to think how long I saw no it's
not by the way I finger song stayed on
number one charts for weeks in my charts
her life charts allies I think ratings
are lie arcing charts or lie they are
having Ward shows their lie LS you know
how do you know how they tell them some
radio ratings they give a guy they get
people this this device you hook it up
to your leg pants and wherever you walk
it records and sends the data back right
then they tell you who fought who's
getting [ __ ] listeners and [ __ ] it's
all [ __ ] dude the [ __ ] odd
Nielsen boxes have you ever met anybody
wouldn't they don't exist anymore that
Nielsen they haven't existed in years
and years they don't know even more even
more deep conspiracy they're stealing
information from each box that's put in
a home
each box I put in a home is tracking all
information when you get a box from a
cable company you're you are
automatically signing an agreement that
I got ever heard that they can track
your data but here's the thing with that
to use more rely
it's Nielsen Jeff Nielsen that yeah that
was it that was it they wanted to take a
countrywide average that's what that was
no is it about Alexa Faunus but also
alright so dis falls me who gives a [ __ ]
I'm not saying to give a [ __ ] I'm just
I'm just smelling it so they try fed
that's how they track what you're really
watching do pretty accurate Oh see how
to stop how to stop TV Smart TV room
tracking don't you watch it for them
what I'm talking about
good night now there's you talk about
ratings yeah ratings are accumulated
from what's these but the boxes are
feeding information back to a server so
where can we find that I'm not saying
you're not right just ratings Smart TVs
I'm top not everybody my mom does not
have a smart TV older people do not have
Smart TVs they're telling you that oh
listen listen listen the people that
still use bunny ears like TV TV they
don't they don't count anymore because
my mom's doesn't have she has these this
old cable box yeah we don't want her
known okay if there's a cable feed they
can track but the old like people that
just use bunny ears to a television
people that still you see that saying
it's not right I hope he is no I'm
telling you that's better info than this
[ __ ] they've been putting out what
is that regular TV television with just
antennas just regular old tennis
oh how do they each other how do they
tell TV ratings how do they accumulate
TV ratings how do they write whoa oh
they're tracked there you go
diaries Nielsen ratings that still says
it that doesn't exist anymore I'm
telling you it does look this talent
show they were they were really banking
on they there is no Nielsen boxes they
don't exist anymore I'm telling you they
do cool they've kind of but maybe not
the boxes but they've done something out
with the rating because they still count
CBA RBA RB 5100 household what is that
though well how what is the system I'm
not saying it what's right or wrong not
everyone they're just taking off a
little some of people right they so what
they do is an algorithm tracks a certain
number of people around the globe it
changes on a constant basis over who
they're tracking and that average is
accumulated that's what that wears out
one says that right there how are you do
that okay that's in the BBC I'm talking
the United States how do you go to
how does about board oh this one yeah
it's interesting I I think it's all
[ __ ] but it's all going away knowing
kids do they it sampling yeah I don't
know yeah because now we see the ratings
I know how many hits this is getting I
see the views yep
you can't fake those views you can't
fake that's why you never go Amazon
Prime Amazon Prime's coming on okay you
can't fake the views use I don't make
any no comics who buy views on the
videos like no name them nope amen name
them name never you got a name shame my
minute you know guys that buy hits nope
did I say that yes you did did I or did
I not say that and I tell you Oh cuz I
know someone that my real I know and
I'll call him out who Bryan Callen you
think anybody watches any trash that he
puts out whether it's stand up or on
here I know people that literally put a
piece of paper over the computer so they
just see you and they know how to tune
it out so they don't hear him anymore
because it's [ __ ] trash the fans know
the red rocket should be in this chair
all the time let's explain can we start
a hashtag that says no more Bryan
no no more Bryan please because we're
tired of his [ __ ] lies I was I'm
about to lose 70 pounds in here oh you
want more you lose it you fat pieces
well one more no it's up to you doing
one more that's it this line was making
headlines
oh [ __ ] Joe Rogan covering me and
nakamoto's medical expenses it was like
thirty thousand dollars something like
that can I take something you know badly
he didn't want this out really in the
eye Joe everywhere this would annoy Joe
to know that it's start getting
circulated around because he probably
did it as a cool quiet thing and someone
was like I gotta talk about she didn't
huh she's the one that I'm sure he's I'm
sure he didn't love that yeah cuz Joe is
the kind of guy that does does things
for other people not so other people
know about it dude either being homeless
or probably killed myself
well then let's that's a bummer that
people can say that a lot a lot a bunch
but I'm just I think about all the
people whose careers now are just a
booming because the Rogen hundred
percent I do die ioio Psalm I owe so
much that guy because he's on your
temperature I do not send you guys I
have to pay 10% my royalty dude I got a
35% mother [ __ ]
ignore it no you know what though and I
don't know I won't get too into it but I
just think like there are some people
that do things for other other people
because they want everybody to know and
it sounds like I'm pandering but it's
true he does a lot of things for people
that no one talks about that we we know
internally that we don't even talk about
it sexually both sexually I mean you
know perfect look at me look at me hey
man Cynthia are you back down the road
are you still do this no no this this is
I can get you for Chappelle yeah yeah
yeah that's me go dude you guys should
go with Chappelle at 79 poem Santino and
I was going out on the road with him and
then he said I think I'm gonna do show
to this guy Dave Chappelle Dave
Chappelle did his website J's job when
does this come out by the way today yeah
that's right on 19 well I want to do fun
with it oh sorry
why did you guys didn't catch it goddamn
I love you both of you remember six
months ah dude sorry dude no I'm not the
job this week is in st. Louis it's my
last date for four months because I'm
shooting TV show so please look TV show
me the helium now FX is with little
Dickey me and little Dickey are you in a
TV show together oh no you can't I love
little dick he's my fave
oh you want me to meet him you want you
you want you want you want you to meet
him I don't know I don't know what I'm
gonna do with this I just want you know
I love little Dickey I love little
Dickey well yeah I'm all set on friend
why don't I put you guys on the show
done you know if fun it would be if I
got cat and chin on the show and not I
would love to get them on the show um
yeah so come see me I'm shooting fur no
don't have two and a half months or
three months and I'm not gonna be on the
robe ah you like in sexual I'm getting
sexual did not well it's about little
Dickey moving to it's about his life a
white Jew from Philly moves to Larry
David but yeah it's like it's like rap
curb there you go hip-hop curb so come
see me this weekend at helium and st.
Louis I'll be that's my last date for a
long time st. Louis have you done it
before no never
I'm there next week are you really um
saying look me and you trail each other
we did Phoenix right after each other
yeah we did another club yes a major no
no no I just want to be him so I said
get his date Sam we're gonna get work in
the years but this week I'm going to be
a Harlow's in Sacramento and then the
following week I am May
and I'm in Indianapolis and I'm in st.
Louis and you check out my special for
free go to Sam's or go to youtube.com
backslash Sam triple e zero [ __ ]
Armageddon available for free if you
want the album it drops on Friday check
it go get it stands on the besties
reason I got started Sandow so give them
some respect I'll be in Nashville
tomorrow let me read your dates let me
read your day tomorrow Thursday Friday
same natural Danny's okay I'm gonna be
shop ready please do okay tomorrow all
there being a now shrill dad from
efforts were family I know that sound
really good okay go ahead Nashville
tomorrow the week out there'll be a
Portland 815 age 17 then I'll be at the
Gold Country casino not a gambler hahaha
doraville California on the 31st and
then I'll be a Houston 922 921 that I go
to Denver I love Denver because it's my
home nine twenty six two nine
twenty-eight a billion to check out all
the days at key facts calm natural see
you tomorrow Thursday Friday Saturday
zany's get on them Portland tea fat K
calm and we're just releasing and I'm
not doing just good Sam's here
we're really sorry a 51 T fat cake
collab tomorrow bye p.m. Pacific
get them listen to whiskey ginger it's a
great hot when I'm not on this I'm over
the fall hat with Sam Tripoli
punch-drunk sports there you go guys
thanks for coming on and love you
filling in we love you yes is the
fighter in the red rocket we're out yeah
[ __ ]